bell a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi
siamo su scribblenauts unlimited
eravamo rimasti che avevamo creato dio
vabbè eravamo rimasti che eravamo in
questa casa infestata e non capisco che
cazzo succede ma sta andando tutto a
fuoco e non ho capito neanch'io comunque
va beh siamo rimasti qui c'è il gargoyle
che è ancora vivo
ti faccio compagnia già bello andiamo da
qualche parte volare insieme
va bene o comunque veramente figo avere
le ali ma posso anche avere tipo jet
perché adesso che mi viene il dubbio
jetpack
no veramente il nostro scrivere jeff
beck ok se possa avere vediamo che è
vega è molto più figo jeff beck mi sento
tipo dj in san andreas comunque va beh a
parte gli scherzi torniamo giu e c'è il
prete che vuole vuole qualcosa che ci
libera mii dal male
amen amen
a me va liberato dal male ameba sei a
posto novero ok cosa far luce lui cioè
cosa devo fare per libera luce
segnalatore illuminazione divina per
liberarlo dal male no come faccio a
liberarti dal male cosa vuol dire non so
prendo lui perché è l'unico che può
venirmi in aiuti in questo momento
liberato dal male ed e vi liberal podio
dio e diavolo si stanno picchiando
questa casa è pulita dio trionfa sempre
veramente tanta stima comunque c'è c'è
qualcun altro di sopra che vuole
qualcosa chi è
pechino ma non da non vuole niente non
lo so perché non ricco mai la star ai
temi di mental c'è il pianoforte che
vuole qualcosa giustamente e poi certo
cavaliere allora facciamo un attimo se
sfide e poi cambiamo zona facciamo una
festa no problema
ok va bene è lampo lampo facciamo una
festa vai così la cerniera e
indispensabile allora una festa cosa
vuoi per una festa palla da discoteca
col pianoforte c'azzecca che una
meraviglia vai con la festa set
[Musica]
ok basta divertitevi raga sballate vi
fate anche un after quello che volete ma
io me ne vado
come sei sexy oggi intanto a un vir dio
il vampiro a vampirizzato la vacca nello
scorso episodio bene questa cosa non la
sapevo come faccio ad andarmene mi
ricordo anzi il mondo perfetto allora
abbiamo sbloccato un casino di zone devo
andare da lì lì per sbloccare la nuova
roba che l'ultimo episodio non c'era
andato
intanto ragala roccia la sta volgendo
sempre di più chi è questo
oddio tipo avatar ma chi cazzo sono
questi perché c'è un dinosauro ok
c'è un vai a mangiarti dinosauro arrivo
ok la maledizione sta sempre peggiorando
la che dobbiamo salvarla intanto abbiamo
sbloccato della nuova roma andiamo di
qua che mi sembra figo cascate di
anafora bene non so che cosa sono c'è
una rana fantastico mi è venuta cascate
diana prince
prevedo che sarà fantastico dio c'è
stato un incidente su una barca come fai
ad avere un incidente su una barca cazzo
sei da ottobre a freddie mercury
perché c'è freddie mercury ok
sì
ok dopo aver conosciuto freddie mercury
posso morire felice anche the freddo non
avrei mai pensato a una cosa del genere
ho aspettato il secondo che voglio
vedere se freddie mercury in costume per
che però è stato un piacere sei un idolo
però devo andare cos'è questo cos'è un
bagnoschiuma me lo prendo io
e vabbè stato un onore veramente c'è una
rana metti qualcosa tra questi ceppi per
evitarmi attraversare il fiume
facciamo un gommone ma vai col gommone
emigra perfetti bene il gommone
evidentemente ha funzionato bene e c'è
una star che c'è una st wright trasforma
un uomo d'affari in un pescatore ma che
cazzo di sfida vi rappresenta allora fa
vigenti insegnerà a diventare un
pescatore provetto questo uomo sogna di
essere un pescatore
per prima cosa a vestire modo
appropriato ci penso io
cappello di paglia di paglia qui paglia
ok cappello di paglia da messicano da
barcaiolo vai col cappello da barcaiolo
adesso sei a posto
beh ok che successo perché c'è poi deve
prendere del pesce dargli un oggetto per
tirarlo su
e non è un arpione non con la canna da
pesca andiamo più pesante arpione ok va
bè scava l'eletto pesca i pesci non
abboccano mette qualcosa per far giocare
nell'acqua guarda dato che sembri
veramente il tipo di moby dick io farei
così così almeno siamo a posto vai o è
quello di moby dico è quello dello
squalo uno dei due comunque vabbè
comunque plancton per ok non so neanche
perché cazzo lo creato sinceramente
mangime per pesci non lo so vai c'è
anche il mangime per giusto io non mi
riesco a spiegare come facciano i
creatori di scribblenauts a materializza
far materializzare qualsiasi cosa tu
crei perché è spuntato un passion dog è
ora di catturare il pesce è un pesce
arcobaleno quello ha davvero un sapore
variegato il pesce arcobaleno ma che
cazzo vuoi da me lo devo catturare io
non sai neanche pescara allora vado io
bene mi piace mangiare il cibo colorato
panino multicolor multicolore panino
cibo ok va e mangiati so tramezzino
arcobaleno perfetto vai lei pescate
ok ci siamo all'ultimo che cosa sarà un
cattura uno scollo di ciò uno squalo di
cioccolato no io qua devo togliermi una
curiosità ma voi che avete creato
scriverlo ma che cazzo vi siete fumati
prima la nostra scuola di cioccolato
facciamo lo svizzero
no no vi dai anche perché perché gli
orsi nudo sicuro ma non ci credo ma ce
l'hai uncat macellai anche teen
scribblenauts se non sapete cos'è perché
ce l'hai anche teen scrive l'on
beh non penso che sia questa la
soluzione però è veramente fantastico
non lo so ci sono rimasto male comunque
non so tavoletta di cioccolato tavoletta
coperchio pietra igiene non c'è la
tavoletta di di genere igiene tavoletta
la tavoletta del sesso di cioccolato
perfetto e se la mangia pure c'è
vabbè
poche domande ragazzi e mangiato una
tavoletta si è mangiato la tavolozza del
cesso di cioccolato fantasti comunque by
con la star hai già bene ci siamo 13
allora la tavoletta del cesso di
cioccolato è stato veramente fantastico
poche domande andiamo avanti c'è la tipa
a terra per favore riunisci mia mio
amore
non so catena ok catena strumento un'ara
collega lei vega e l'altra collego a lui
perfetto
adesso siete uniti auguri e figli maschi
cosa cosa vuoi
cosa vuoi tu vabbè dai facciamo i buoni
per stavolta è che ne so defibrillatore
allora come ho fatto nello scorso
episodio vai così libera perfetto è viva
luna di miele struggente ok adesso siete
uniti nel vero senso della parola tipo l
kira è inoltre più anche di animata
perfetto è bene devo fare qualcosa per
la barca
aiutami a riprendere la navigazione ok
allora facciamo diluvio universale per
spegnere il fuoco che non mi sembra un
diluvio universale ma non importa ok
siamo tipo mosè per piuttosto faceva
un'arca a sto punto
aiutami a riprendere la navigazione che
cosa vuoi che faccia le assi giustamente
devo spingerla ok allora prova a fare
così transatlantico oddio peggio del
titanic è poi dato che la catena sembra
essere così utile allora scusatemi un
secondo se mi separo ma mi serve poi vi
riunisco ve lo prometto
e allora transatlantico ci siamo montava
vai maledetto stronze pezone titanic in
fondo all'oceano smonta perfetto ok devo
portarla su come faccio a portarla su mi
serve tipo un elica e lì con l'ico però
adesso dovremmo essere in grado perfetto
se riesco a creare un'altra catena devo
essere in grado dovrei essere in grado
di portarla su chi guarda che cazzo sono
costretto a fare per girare su una nave
ma vi rendete conto ok
vai elimina no no che cazzo fatto sì
però no merda
affondiamo may day may day may day ok
cazzo stiamo affondando perfetto allora
ci rinuncio maledizione [ __ ] la
barca [ __ ] a voi due e me ne vado
perché ci sono dei piranha lì sotto
siamo piranha vegetariani che si mangia
uomo vegetariano italiano ok
vai cos'è ok allora facciamo uomo pianta
no vabbè allora direte in questo caso un
piatto di insalata è il massimo
vai così nutrire pirani esigenti
perfetto io solo in scrive l'alto visto
degli perché ho preso una star ai tassi
per con completato una sfida prefetto 14
sole in scribblenauts ho visto dei
piranha vegetariani veramente baule
svuota tipo quelli di skyrim c'è perché
cazzo cioè un oggetto o cazzo che chi
cazzo è questo scheletro pesante sì
veramente tipo in scarino aperto il
baule ho trovato uno scheletro a sto
punto
fus rho da ok dvd
sesso dvd the ok prendi ok ti sei
incazzato no vabbè dai facciamo
non lo so bazooka provava a metterti
contro fa vj brutto stronzo
ok dovahkiin quanto vuoi ma bazooka non
lo batte nessuno e quindi devo cambiare
zona perfetto allora qui l'abbiamo fatto
credo e andiamo qui che non so che cos'è
parco dei sauri andiamo nel ragazzo
grassi park raga andiamo in jurassic
park
c'è il professor hoc perfetto e ci sono
tutti i nostri lavori
odio la brass bene ok ragazzi siamo
jurassic park
non ho capito bene sinceramente che cosa
ci stiamo facendo qui ho perso il mio
pterodattilo viola poi ritrovarmelo
giustamente uno si sveglia la mattina e
si accorge di aver perso uno
pterodattilo viola the road a kg non è
che se si scrive così forse ho sbagliato
ma di sicuro sbagliato viola no non ho
sbagliato perfetto tieni te l'ho
ritrovato come la felice ovi o non
rompere il cazzo dopo trovato dello
trovato cosa vuoi loro vedi e 120
dattilo viola
ok non gli va bene magari non è propone
proprio suo stronzo ok perfetto va beh
allora te lo trovo più avanti intanto
c'è questa che da un'asta wright quindi
alla precedenza trova e cattura
l'allosauro fuggito
ok allosauro in fuga perfetto andiamo
tipo ok c'è e sarebbe quello universale
è fuggito che a qualcuno che possa
aiutare a ritrovarlo
ma dov'è finito dinosauro cattivo non lo
trovo veramente la canon si vede che si
sta nascondendo e per carità mi serve un
t rex cavalcabile possibilmente no no
maledetto stronzo allora aggiungiamo
mettiamo un aggettivo blocco appunti
aggiunge aggettivo facciamo domestico
chi non vorrebbe un t rex domestico ad
ora fermo li monta perfetto allora raga
la nostra buonissima catena katana
catena ci tornerà utile sempre ci torna
di nuovo utile e quindi andiamo ad
attaccare il dinosauro al t rex perfetto
brutto stronzo esce se ce la sto facendo
vai di rex mai tirato via teoria bravo
bravo così bravo che cazzo succede ma
sto maledetto tiro più io brutto stronzo
è raga non ho capito bene come fare crea
un calciatore al cacciatore ci vuole
faccio io il cacciatore allora facciamo
fucile narcotizzante non penso
neutralizzante va beh più o meno arma da
caccia vai così ci provo io a stordire
il dinosauro vai brutto strappo
ok bene si sta incalzando si sta
incazzare aiuto apri apri la gabbia a
praga merda merda aiuto
ti ho trovato il top the road attilo
viola ok urge una
da caccia fuggiamo volgiamo cazzo prima
che ci arrivi addosso fuggiamo perfetto
che ho potuto stronzo non avevano ancora
inventato non avevano ancora inventato
gli aerei nel giurassico
e vabbè allora va bene sto punto dai
creiamo il cacciatore che sono ci
mettiamo anni cacciato perché è il
calciatore senza il fucile proprio
guarda prendilo così il calciatore non
trovo alcuna traccia del dinosauro cazzo
ce l'hai di fianco dagli uno strumento
per aiutare a trovare dinosauro facciamo
proprio così guarda occhiali perché mica
ce l'hai di fianco guardano lo vedi è
perfetto giustamente o materializzato un
cacciatore orbo il calciatore è
intenzione di rimettere in gabbia il
dinosauro metti qualcosa nella gabbia
per attirarlo
smonta che cosa posso mettere nella
gabbia per attirare il dinosauro mangia
dinosauri che ne so facciamo bistecca
enorme ok va madonna sempre un mega
hamburger
ok dovremmo esserci o materializzati
indiana jones sorbo c'è questa è
veramente questa è veramente il colmo
raga cosa sta facendo si sta
addormentando cosa i dinosauri ignorato
le score è ora il cacciatore nei guai ma
sei un [ __ ] colpa sua
dai al guardiano dello zoo qualcosa
praticare l'attenzione del dinosauro
diamogli un altra bistecca sto punto
bistecca non so scrivere
vai così attira ok
la cosa veramente stupida il tesoro
sembra molto stanco dopo aver corso così
tanto è stato fermo lì mezz'ora lo
trainato colpire ex come fa a essere
così stanco trova un modo per farlo
addormentare
allora facciamo lezione di matematica
perfette questa funziona con tutti e
nove a parte gli scherzi che cazzo ne so
cuscino cuscino letto addormentate
appoggiati a terra
bravo no non devi mangiare cuscino devi
a ok
ma che cazzo succede allora
ricapitolando gli ho dato un cuscino
se l'è mangiato si è addormentato il
guardiano ha preso letteralmente di
proprio di peso il dinosauro e l'ha
messo nella gabbia
allora io non ho mai visto una scena più
non sense di questa totale st wright 15
continua va bene così
non ho la più pallida idea di che cosa
io abbia appena fatto ma vabbè vabbè
raga direi di chiudere qui l'episodio
perché veramente è successo di tutto
vabbè come al solito se vi è piaciuto il
video lasciato commento mi piace che
cazzo è questo buongiorno sto chiedendo
il video ma deve arrivare un po prima me
lo dicevi e va bene il prossimo episodio
andremo a conoscerlo e andremo a provare
gli altri mondi che intanto mi sono
sbloccato
intanto aspettare un attimo di vedere se
mi sono nomi ma anche una sarai te
sblocco ancora l'altro mondo
ok la prenderemo nel prossimo episodio
con tutti gli altri dinosauri ovviamente
questo era solo l'inizio
vabbè come al solito se vi dove è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non siete ancora iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi